[Music]
these infinity stones wait look i'm out
of the weapons business what are we
watching like how do we put we haven't
seen this before
this is new around the galaxy
you can't tell me there's not another
big bag what are they hiding from us
this was an
erased episode i don't know what's going
on but i don't remember this this is not
something they've changed something
there's a glitch
welcome back to new rock stars marvel
studios what if episode nine the season
finale what if the watcher broke his
oath breaks reality in all kinds of ways
including our reality with a hint of a
missing tenth episode from this season
what were iron man and gamora and itri
doing on nittovaleer what have they
hidden from us
what uh if
this is inside marvel it's our after
show for marvel's what if on disney plus
i'm eric voss my breakdown of all the
easter eggs you missed from the season
finale is coming to the channel tomorrow
but right now to discuss this episode
with me mt you have been chosen
thank you my brother eric dude this
episode was crazy that whole that
killmonger twist i don't understand what
the watcher was expecting out of
killmonger you must know that killmonger
is not a good person why did you pick
him for this team i don't know it just i
mean it seems like that was part of his
plan right like he had it all planned
out man 12 by 12 to the 12th power steps
ahead of everyone
insane that this guy had this level of
thinking seriously i mean if you have a
head that big eric i would expect that
level of thinking like come on man yes
that's true good point good point
i can't do that i don't think i'm in the
big words
not interested
this finale picks up with captain carter
in the present era really following in
the footsteps of steve rogers from the
opening sequence of captain america the
winner soldier against bat truck
man george st pierre
getting those checks from disney plus i
love how he's like i'm so fast i'm too
fast
i'm over here
uh but uh captain carter gets recruited
by the watcher he picks his top six
pokemon battle lineup that includes
star-lord t'challa gamora from some huh
episode killmonger party thor and
strange supreme and together they are
the guardians of the insert freaking
here multiverse
only i love this moment
i'm a sucker for any putting the gang
together
i do i love a team i love teams so much
i love a good team now they meet in
peggy's pub and i love this there's
something kind of uh agents of shield
about this right just hanging out in the
bar just like creating that out of
nothing perfect right and they devised
this battle strategy against ultron
infinity meanwhile killmonger for voting
lead tinkers with an ultron sentry head
someone could have said like hey can we
get that away from him
i don't know what he's doing with it but
i don't know that guy
and he's looking at it real weird it's
like you uh you like this a little bit
too much this is uh we're taking this
away from you sorry so they waged war
with ultron infinity and empty this
battle rocks i love this i love it so
much strange uses magic to armor up
everyone i'm like oh this is fun i'm
having fun uh he creates duplicate
mjolnirs and they all like
and one just kind of thinks like the
late ones
like literally like like battle on titan
vibes with this yeah hardcore yeah uh it
was it was great but it felt like
another dimension to it because you can
use animation do all kinds of crazy
stuff not like the you know with vfx
pretty much everything is animated in a
sense but uh they just kind of went
crazy with it i enjoyed it uh he reigns
zombies including zombie wanda max mop
on old trucks oh my god i screamed when
i saw her i screamed yeah i like it was
just like a car trash dump
just all right pouring out world war z
messages straight out of the devil's
anus right up to
like where were they before that dad had
he gathered them all like in a big um
like i think i'm walking dead at one
point they just kind of gather all the
walkers into just like a big pit of them
that's exactly what happened let's just
keep pushing them in here and hopefully
they don't get out now during this
t'challa with his sticky fingers
snatches the soul stone and they return
to ultron's original earth in new york
city and they continue to fight and
they're able to pin him long enough for
more to use the infinity crusher to
pulverize the six stones but then
suddenly infinity stone logic matters on
this show so this doesn't work
yeah we'll talk about it and black widow
plugs ultron with that zola ai arrow and
zola neutralizes ultron's ai now why
didn't the watcher recruit black widow
if she had this ace in the hole to begin
with
yeah i don't know this was part of his
plan everything was part of his play it
hasn't don't question it it had to
happen specifically that way um and then
killmonger
man that [ __ ] huge [ __ ] he's
always looking out for himself 100
he uses that century head i guess it
still has some of ultron's consciousness
in it so he can still have access to the
infinity stones use the reality stone to
assemble his new killmonger infinity
suit uh and he offers to write all the
wrongs the multiverse but then zola's ai
awakens in the synthazoid's tummy
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm so happy that we got that it was so
exciting that was wonderful
and then the two of them tug of war over
the stones but that is what the watcher
wanted so he had strange supreme trap
them in a pocket reality and it leaves
strange to just kind of hang out and
watch this snow globe for all of
eternity seriously kind of messed up
kind of messed up but okay i mean at
least give him like a sofa to sit on
seriously he's just standing there it's
like all right thanks was gonna hold
this forever
like a disney plus bundle you know so we
could just have something else to kind
of watch seriously
like come on watch her
so the warriors return to their home
realities except black widow she goes to
that episode three avengers lists
reality to help captain america and
captain carter defeat loki on a
helicarrier meanwhile back in captain
carter's reality from the beginning of
the episode natasha reveals bacharach
was after the hydra stomper armor from
the first episode with someone inside
probably skinny steve we'll talk about
what that is but at the moment honestly
most of my questions about this mystery
lost episode about gamora and iron man
it's a car you mean to tell us there's
one universe where tony stark actually
lives
thank god
but what happened there why was this
episode removed
that will be our main uh question for
this episode but you are running out of
time to grab a what if latest obsession
shirt on newrockstarsmerch.com they are
close to running out of stock and when
they're gone they will be locked in the
blue dungeon forever whatever there's
also a shirt inspired by let there be
carnage and a few of the shanxi laced
obsession shirts remaining so if you buy
one of the latest obsession shirts you
will get the option to leave a custom
shout out that will run during the
bottom of inside marvel episodes william
asks will the tva get flooded with nexus
events during the ultron uwatu fight as
they break through each universe good
question where was the tva and all this
seriously
i hope that they were just watching it's
like hell this is like we've never seen
this before let's just see how this
plays out
i mean maybe the watcher the fact that
he was able to patch it all up the tv is
like no no we got a guy on the inside
he's gonna make sure it's all okay by
the end of it this was all part of the
sacred timeline that the watcher was
able to to to
uh well leah asked since christine
palmer's death is an absolute point does
that mean she will die in multiverse of
madness
well it depends on if you see absolute
points as being absolute to their own
timelines or to all timelines i've made
the argument that tony stark's death is
absolute in all timelines uh whereas
other absolute points could just be
absolute to their own timelines uh so i
could see christine palmer surviving in
multiverse yeah i think that that
absolute point was just for strange
supreme's universe and not yeah a
constant uh and then ryan asks what if
eric was thanos well i wouldn't be able
to strike the booty poses that
i doubt that eric i think you could do
it you could do it i tried i pulled
things bro and i agree 100 squats a day
and you'll be there by february
[Applause]
well what's our big question coming out
of this episode mt well eric what if
there was a missing 10th episode of this
season of what if okay yeah so before
this season began the episode number at
the last minute was adjusted from 10
episodes to nine episodes they said one
episode was being moved to the second
season producers said coven made it so
that one episode wouldn't be ready in
time
i don't believe that because you can
socially just produce animation with
minimal delays there isn't just that to
be made but like it seems like they were
working on all these episodes throughout
2019 before covid anyway
like we saw a teaser for what these
episodes were going to be they totally
could have gotten this done especially
since the first episode of the show came
out on august 11th you know you have
time until october
6th
uh i think there might have been
something that ended up overlapping with
something that will come out in the
movies and they didn't want probably
that's my guess or they're like no we
want tony stark to die in every episode
i honestly i think those are two very
good points especially the tony stark
one because the tony stark died in
pretty much every one of his appearances
is too much of a coincidence to be
ignored so like the fact that they
probably was like hey tony stark
survives in this universe that doesn't
really jive with the theme of the show
so let's just
push this on over to season two
well let's talk about what we think this
episode was it now appears that that
episode was going to be titled what if
gamora killed thanos
now as the watcher goes to recruit the
heroes of the past episodes to his team
he travels to knit of a lear where e
tree is melting the infinity gauntlet in
his forge and he's joined by gamora who
is carrying thanos double-bladed sword
that we saw in in-game and tony stark
who's wearing it looks like hulk buster
armor decorated with sakhar art and the
watcher greets her as gamora survivor of
sakaar and destroyer of thanos
now we were all checking our notes
during this moment momentarily thinking
that doctor strange might have mandela
affected us but no
in fact we never saw this episode and
the question is now is when and how did
gamora defeat thanos why is iron man
with her
so thanos had the infinity gauntlet
which means this is relatively recent
like right as he began his stone quest
sometime between 2015 and 2017. but
weirdly
in the shot ichri still has his hands
now in the films when thanos forced itre
to forge the gauntlet he cut off his
hands he cast the stumps in urus so he
could never make anything else right so
this must be some alternate series
events altogether or
e tree lied about what they just did to
him and he tripped in the forgery and he
fell into some hot pokers and he's like
ah and then he dips his hands and
urine's like that's not water
i'd like to think it was a flirkin that
just scratched his hands up like the
whole nick theory
you're all oh
nuts i can't even snap now based on all
the evidence we saw here i could see a
few ways this missing episode went so um
maybe perhaps hulkbuster tony not hulk
hulkbuster tony from age of ultron ended
up on the quinjet to sakaar at the end
of that movie and then hulkbuster's tony
stark becomes the sakai gladiator
champion oh my god i would hello
that episode my dude oh my god that'd be
so much fun like we just got a fast
track throughout all the events of thor
ragnarok and then like uh tony stark
jumps from the
from the grand master's ship to the
bifrost bridge thinking he could do that
avengers move and his hulkbuster armor
could uh assemble around him but it does
it in time and he just like
flattens on the bridge
and maybe it would have been tony who
ended up in thor's place floating
through the space when he ran into the
guardians to begin infinity war and it
was him who joined forces with gamora to
stop thanos from requiring the rest of
the stones and then maybe gamora's
dagger to the neck move could have
worked this time
and just because they had the brilliant
tony stark with them they were able to
get ahead of the game a bit sooner
before thanos was able to quickly gather
everything right that hulk buster tony
on the car thing sounds extremely likely
to be that's a really good thing that's
gotta be a part of it right but there's
also like weirdness like why is gamora
just why is gamora we can stop the
question why is that laura why is gamora
but why is she there and i think
maybe there was another wrinkle to this
where thanos could have sacrificed
nebula on vermeer instead of gamora like
thanos society do you know what i
actually love this uh android
daughter who i severely abused i kind of
love her a bit more and then maybe he
was able to use nebula to get the soul
stone and then uh that left gamora alive
to join tony and the others to fight
thanos and this time peter quill
wouldn't have been grieving
so he wouldn't have punched thanos out
of that mantis trance and they could
have wriggled the gauntlet off thanos
hand from there and then use the
infinity crusher and then just melted
the gauntlet as we see them do
uh because it's just weird that gamora
is alive here uh
this would have happened earlier than
than the sakara events on ragnarok it
sounds like because why would you visit
the car another time um
and there's also like i don't know maybe
since episode two showed the grand
master ships in the collector's vault
maybe there's some universe where these
two elders traded
like made some kind of trade and the
reality stone ended up on sakaar and
that's why thanos targeted zakar instead
there's just like a lot of different
possibilities here but i think there's
some version of the events where tony
stark at the end of the events of age of
ultron right around the time when dana
said fine i'll do it myself somehow
through some kind of accident ended up
on sakhar and it kind of followed the
path of of hulk from those events where
he was off world yeah you could also
imagine tony stark was not on earth
during civil war that's an interesting
thing to explore
but then at the same time thanos
sacrificed
nebula instead of gamora and i think
those two things came together to
produce what we saw at the end of this
episode uh and i assume some kind of
combination of everything we've talked
about hopefully we'll be when we see
this episode in season two but the weird
thing is now that this gamora was
already pulled for the guardians of the
multiverse finale
will this gamora episode even matter to
what happens to season two well maybe
because tony hinted at some other big
bad lurking in the shadows a monster
under the bed almost sounded like they
got mick winger to kind of like do some
last-minute audio add-in there because
like why is tony suddenly so freaked out
over this like you would think like why
can't he just like melt this thing and
just be happy the way everyone else is
just kind of like haha done with my
thing like the fact that he's suddenly
so freaked out about this it seemed like
they sandwiched in a kind of fear for
something beyond to justify them
bringing this into season two who do you
think that next bigger threat could be
empty oh that's a good thing how do you
top ultron infinity
now that's a really good question
because like we still haven't seen the
tentacle monsters i thought that we
would have the whole tentacle monster
payoff in this finale but we haven't
seen them pop up since you know really
since that first episode i think that
maybe that mystery tenth episode was
going to be like oh and then the
tentacle monsters that we brought up and
like that's the mystery threat but they
were like you know what let's just say
that for season two like we don't need
to tease it like let's just let this end
on like a good note we're like a
a pretty positive note with the whole
peggy and steve thing like sort of
mirroring the end game ending maybe like
they didn't know if they were gonna do a
season two like because this this was
very much an experimental show so maybe
they were just like hey like let's not
tease something if we're not really
guaranteed if we're gonna have a season
two uh i think like they very likely
could come back on this series um in
terms of like a big bad like to top
infinity ultra and you kind of need to
have something with more of a face more
of a
a personality uh and some people are
talking about galactus or kang you know
i think kang is obviously going to be a
major threat to the whole emcee for sure
specifically to what if though they can
really get specific with the toy box
and play with really anyone like ultron
infinity is really they just took an old
villain and they're like but what if he
had this so they could do that with any
of their past villains conceivably um i
am wondering if like the bigger threat
we're gonna see is like the council of
watchers you know like it seemed like
the question of this episode is what if
the watcher broke his oath and we didn't
really see any consequences for him for
breaking his oath this is true he seemed
to kind of just get away with exactly
what his plan was and then it's like
well then why didn't they interfere
earlier why don't you interfere more and
seriously recruit more badasses from the
multiverse is there really no one left
you can't tell me that there's no one
there's gotta be someone adam warlock is
somewhere i i really wanted them to get
into the past of the watcher and like
why he watches this episode was
literally called why like what if the
watcher broke his oath it's just kind of
weird that we didn't see the motivations
behind the watcher in this episode but i
mean there's always season two but i got
enough to like know why he would do what
he's doing like clearly he cares a lot
about the the balance of the multiverse
and he wants to keep it
intact as much as he can uh but just
specifically that oath in the titleist
episode i think that's what we'll
explore in season two it's kind of like
the way what we do in the shadows season
one ended and he realized that they're
part of like this network this
bureaucracy of vampires right they had
this trial and that's kind of how they
heighten it is like you realize oh no
there's like a layer of bureaucracy to
this it's basically how loki is like the
loki method too of like all these
actions are taking place within a
framework of people doing paperwork you
know
and to me that's what i find most
amusing because it's the way you also
ground things at the same time because
we all have to like wait in lines at
dmvs and [ __ ] we can relate with that
more easily when you try to heighten
things um so that's my hope i would hope
that we
uh heightened by going more mundane and
by doing so you can also just heighten
the stakes of everything true and i
guess infinity stones already don't
matter and they matter as much as you
want them to so
they're plot stones
but no i think i i would really love if
in season two we got a conversation
between the watcher and mordo because
mordo is all about like the bill coming
due and like you know the price needed
to be paid yeah and the watcher did
violate his oath and so i wonder if
there was going to be a price there on a
multiversal scale so i i hope that we do
see uh chiwetel egypt iv or a chiwetel
egfor impressionist she would tell egf5
um coming out
to voice him
yeah chewatel and uh groot and rocket uh
characters that it's like i could use a
bit more of you guys oh absolutely like
it's just so weird that we just didn't
get more rocket like specifically rocket
or cause like they're just so easy to no
they're so easy to plug in anywhere yeah
yeah i could have used a bit less of
like non-date batista tracks and non-uh
larson captain marvel in the show and
just like maybe one more episode to some
of those guys if you're gonna use voice
actors to replace them anyway i feel
like an i am groot impression you don't
need vin diesel to do that unless he has
it in his contract he's like the only
people who stay up
like i'm sure you have enough recordings
at this point to just shove them in like
at night i'm not vin diesel
writes his contracts a quarter page at a
time he's very careful about what how
his stuff is used and there's no way
you're going to bring in his audio again
without him getting a paycheck true the
oscar performance yeah clearly well
before we continue it's fun to watch
what if episodes but even uh doesn't
like watching one thing a growing credit
card balance upstart can help lift that
burden upstart is a fast and easy way to
pay off your debt with a personal loan
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses over
half a million people have used upstart
to get a simple fixed monthly payment
unlike other lenders upstart looks at
more than just your credit score like
your income your employment history that
means they can offer smarter rates with
trusted partners with a five minute
online rate check you can see your rate
up front for loans between one thousand
and fifty thousand dollars you can
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com marvel that's upstart.com
marvel don't forget to use r url to let
them know that we sent you loan amounts
to be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com marvel also it's fall and
halloween is right around the corner
that means it's time to watch some scary
movies well there's no better place to
do that than on shudder the netflix of
horror you can stream great thrillers
horror and suspense for 5.99 a month or
56.99 per year shutter has the largest
fastest growing curated selection of
thrilling and dangerous entertainment
stream on apple and android xbox or
however you watch your content it's ad
free and they have an excellent mix of
classics and new stuff and some
unexpected surprises all presented in an
uncluttered interface i really love
browsing through shutter it's just like
i'm in the mood to be scared right now
ooh
everything i could possibly want to be
scared by uh now around the office we
all have our favorites on the platform
including train to busan mandy we got
team the whaling we got team classic
poltergeist i mean that's me right
there here i love it i'll watch it every
year oh we actually watched poltergeist
on a new rockstars retreat last october
we got to do another one of those
retreats empty we're gonna drag you
somewhere into a cabin
in the middle of the southern california
desert and make you watch a scary movie
you're gonna make me scared ah i don't
know if i can handle it but i'm ready oh
you're ready uh they have a great
collection of uh exclusive and original
programming our editor drew is a huge
fan of the joe bob briggs last drive-in
series they got a new special airing
this week it started streaming the best
horror thriller and supernatural content
shutters expertly curated collection
includes must-see titles like vicious
fun the mortuary collection and pg
psycho gourmand plus all the best horror
documentaries in the hit creep show tv
series from executive producer greg
nicotero the walking dead so to try a
shutter for free for 30 days go to
shutter.com and use the promo code rogue
that's s-h-u-d-d-e-r.com
promo code rogue
and guys there's nothing sexier than
confidence and blue chew can help give
you the confidence where it counts
on your on your dick the penis yes yes
[Laughter]
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost you can take them any time day
or night so you can plan ahead or be
ready whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive a
prescription within days and the best
part it's all done online so no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations no waiting in line at the
pharmacy bluetooth tablets are made in
the usa and prepared and shipped direct
to your door in a discrete package so if
you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
bluetooth can help you and we've got a
special deal for our listeners try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code inside marvel at checkout just pay
the five dollars in shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code inside marvel
to receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode all right empty back to this
finale discussion what if skinny steve
is still alive in that hydro stomper in
the post-credits scene what do you think
they could set up for season two
i love how the the season ended like
this because i was like
what if it's like the corpse of skinny
steve just get this skeleton
beetle coming out of his eyeball
he's like i got a gift for you bestie
it's your ex-boyfriend skydiving someone
inside
[Applause]
she's always starting the skin stretched
across buns
now you can bury him yourself i was like
oh thank you black widow and then
captain britain is like why did you
think i would want this
black widow's like that's how i grieve
with my grandmother look here's my mama
here's my papa i found him in an
unmarked grave at a chain-link fence in
russia thank you
thanks daddy ivan
this is how everyone reunites with their
loved ones no is this not
that would be the episode of what if i
want to see right but like no i find it
really like interesting about the fact
that skinny steve could still be alive
in this universe somehow and like it's
probably going to have to do with like
the whole winter soldier parallels like
he maybe he got frozen somehow
or like maybe like he was trying to get
peggy back and so he was working
together with howard stark to like go
through portals and like try to you know
find peggy so like maybe this is just a
steve that just finally found his way
back to the proper timeline where his
boo thing is i like the idea you brought
up the winter soldier thing maybe we're
gonna see winter soldier steve rogers
and then like the hydro stomper was
taken by hydra and that was used as his
like cryo cell to kind of rejuvenate him
every time to send him back out on
deployment now he would still be skinny
steve i mean i don't know maybe he was
like he
was basically immortalized in some way
with some kind of de-aging serum but he
has to stay in this winter this hydra
stomper armor as kind of an iron lung
like there was uh who was uh tony
stark's brother in the comics who had to
be like in an iron lung that was like
howard and maria's first kid arnold
stark yeah yeah like maybe that's kind
of the direction they go with skinny
steve is he's just basically he's super
power because he's always in this armor
but he can never leave it and he's this
tragic figure i mean it would make it
kind of dark for blackwood to be like
there's someone inside
like it's gonna be really freaking dark
for you guys right i didn't read the
product label when
cracked open this crate what's really
weird is that black widow was trying to
set up peggy at the beginning of this
episode which she knew bernard and
account bernard accounted like she knew
that she had this special gift for peggy
like why are you doing that why are you
trying to set her up
maybe behind that arm or bernard in the
county comes out with some towers like
hello
would you like to look at some
spreadsheets
slow
smile that would be so funny
you she was just trying to set up peggy
that'd be so funny sorry i know it's
like
i don't know why i'm crying bernard what
were you doing at this crate the whole
time
oh just playing the solo version of
wingspan
another plug for the greatest board game
of all time winks oh my god i'm
literally crying i don't know why i
thought that was such a funny scenario
yeah
uh well let's talk about zola
empty what if zolatron that's what i'm
calling him and killmonger infinity ever
escaped from strange's supreme pocket
reality it seemed like that was the
implication he ever takes his eye off
the ball at one point these two are
gonna crack out of that egg and then go
fart everywhere so what do you think's
gonna happen if these two others ever
escape do you think they'll ever escape
oh yeah they're definitely going to
escape like they're not just gonna stay
in that prison forever and i think that
how they escape is that they're probably
gonna work together because zola and
killmonger are very two conniving people
and so they're probably gonna be like
you know what why are we even fighting
you know you seem like a a very smart
brown man we could team together and
take over the the multiverse and kill
monkeys would be like what do you mean
by brown and then they're not gonna work
together
yeah could be replacing radiant defense
to that
it's like when you're mean brown oh yeah
you don't want to buy 1950s
can i get it different can i get a
different plug
anyone want to trade with me because
racist swiss is trying to team up with
me and i don't want to do it but no but
no seriously uh zola and killmonger are
probably going to end up like striking a
truce and then working together to burst
their way out of the bubble and then
stretch gonna be like oh we have a
problem uh they're back and they're
working together and the multiverse is
in trouble and so they're gonna have to
make a bigger
guardians of the multiverse team so
that's what i think but what do you
think mt remember during falcon winter
soldier episode one there was that swiss
bank and we're like that's where zola
keeps
[Laughter]
[Applause]
no i think so i think it's a matter of
time i think what we'll see is every
season they'll probably add a new
multiversal threat to this pocket
reality to just be trapped in this like
voldemort harry uh
want connection moment
and just keep adding people to it until
it becomes a pandora's box and they all
get out like that's going to be their
version of ravencroft or arkham you know
you just keep throwing people in there
and eventually they all get out i think
that's what is in that scenario like
what if the watcher does that and he
shoves a bunch of people in this prison
and then strange is like oh yeah it's
totally fine i'll just watch this and
then he just goes
because he comes and he loves to eat all
these things
he loves stuff that was insane it's just
so i feel like he would do that i feel
like he would just totally eat those
prisoners and be like oh you guys seem
like a delicious power meal
because you know strange supreme is
technically still a villain like i do
not trust that man at all even though
that's right was on the side of good
he's very much a greedy magician so well
he had the squid monster come out of his
hand and then they're like whoa
what happened what was that
i'm good i'm good i'm totally fine
and then he used it to you know fight
giant infinity ultron but like i want to
see more come out of it that's not good
you know yeah i want to see more
consequences well before we continue our
friends at audible would like to remind
you to listen to the sandman act 2 on
audible right now the next part to the
number one new york times bestseller the
sandmans available for your listening
pleasure enter the dreaming again and
journey into the world of myths
imagination and terror based on the dc
graphic novels written by the great neil
gaiman the epic voice cast is led by
james mcavoy as morpheus lord of dreams
and includes brian cox and kat dimmings
john litko jeffrey wright and so many
more the blockbuster audio adaptation is
the greatest epic in the history of
comic books continues and it expands
into the french revolution in ancient
rome 19th century san francisco 8th
century baghdad and beyond it's
never only a dream so go to audible.com
dreaming and listen now so empty we got
to talk about the watch of this episode
what if the watcher actually planned
everything as he seems to have why
didn't he recruit heavier hitters and
what consequences will he have to face
to the other watchers oh man that's a
really good question because like you
know he recruited these specific people
when he definitely could have recruited
like a captain marvel or something like
uh maybe even like
there's like a multiverse full of
destroyer armors i don't know why he
just didn't go for that but anyway yeah
so i think that he like he very much had
the specific vision in mind ever since
you know he was
watching a nat and clint you know pick
up like those files in that in that
little kgb area he was like you know
what like this is the specific path i
need these specific players yeah so i
think he knew exactly what he needed to
do because he's a very efficient person
he has a big brain you gotta remember
that and i feel like having heavier
hitters would probably attract ultron
because like if you have like you know
like a a surging power source that is
like captain marvel on this planet and i
feel like ultron would like what's going
on here hmm a lot faster than he did
because he did end up fighting them yeah
i i think specifically
they needed like i i don't think he
played his team before ultron infinity
arrived i think clearly he was caught
off guard by that and then that plan
formed with him and doctor strange at
the end of episode eight i think that's
when he started playing everything out
uh including who he would invite and why
he needed this specific team i think he
needed uh people like a mix of people
who could be just you know uh directed
chaos the way party thor is uh he needed
some more tactical
uh sticky finger snatchers like t'challa
and i think he needed someone who could
rival uh ultron infinity uh he needed
like zola to detach the the mind from
him but it needed to happen at the same
time that killmonger would be right
there and could just be just as uh power
hungry as ultron is and the two of them
could just kind of neutralize each other
in this pocket reality so i'm gonna have
to spend some more time thinking about
each step of the plan but i think the
end goal was he needed killmonger's
selfishness right
uh and he needed zola to be part of it
what's still kind of hard for me to
imagine right now is why didn't he just
bring natasha there sooner to plug in
that thing because it seems like there
was just a lot of steps like ultron got
back the soul stone at that point my
only thing is like there needed to be a
first wave so that ultron felt confident
in this moment and started to glow
bright so that someone specifically on
their home turf in this case wanda
maximoff could get the the jump on them
and then plug it in there that's that's
the only thing i would have there but
like clearly the failure of the infinity
crusher was part of that plan like they
needed to basically have ultron feel
like he won the first round so that he
felt like this is the best you got and
someone could sneak up behind and get
him but it does sound like a lot of
steps i'll agree i've d chest i feel
like a lot of the times with the
infinity stones in various you know
universes whether it's the comics are
animated it's the
the hubris of the wielder that ends up
being the downfall of the the infinity
stone wielder exactly pride goes before
the fall
but uh let's end on this question about
the infinity stones let's just
take a step back and react to the way
what if use the infinity stones
throughout the episodes and in this
final episode there's this little moment
where gamora goes oh right infinity
stones only are unique to their own home
reality so the infinity stone crusher
won't work against ultron's infinity
stones uh because it's from my past
reality not this one
cool i wish you were saying that the
whole time but then like there was a
moment where doctor strange uses the
time stone his time stone
against ultron who has his own time
stone so clearly they're saying that
like stones can coexist in the same
reality and both have power yet they
never unwind anything the way that the
reality st or the way that the time
stone is supposed to i think that was
their line like they could be big energy
blasts but the specific uses of the
stones outside of their home realities
we're just not going to cross that line
because we don't want to create too many
questions but like i'm thinking why not
you know if you're going to decide they
don't matter why not just say like i'm
going to unwind you no i'm going to
unwind you and then at some point they
just kind of unwind each other and then
the two time stones they're just kind of
locked like two rubik's cubes trying to
solve each other you know they're just
floating off on the side fighting each
other like you know just their own side
battle
there's all kinds of crazy things you
can do to follow that narrative thread
um but you gotta ask the question i
think the infinity stones in this
episode um are variants of each other
and like ultron's infinity stones are
variants of doctor strange's infinity
stone his time stone and so the reason
why
gamora's infinity crusher didn't work
against
ultron stones is because probably like
on a molecular level they're just
different and like it takes different
amounts of force to take them down and
so like maybe like we see this in the
battle between wanda and ultron briefly
in this episode like wanda was supposed
to have the ability to destroy the
stones in our universe that's right
because this was what was a wanda from a
different universe than ultron maybe
like the the
i don't know the on a molecular level
things are different and so like you
can't destroy them but like you can use
infinity stones in any universe that you
want but like the process of destroying
them is going to be different because
it's a different even though the two
like two time stones could look the same
they're different on the inside yeah no
i think you're right i think that is the
show's rule i just think it's a flawed
piece of logic to suggest that you can
use them in alternate universes without
blinking an eye but you cannot destroy
them you know it's like they can either
exist or they can't exist and i think
that's the kind of line the show has
walked and saying it doesn't matter but
every time you say like it doesn't
matter like nothing is has been more
debated in the marvel cinematic universe
than like what exactly the infinity
stones are the the first era of the
movies was called the infinity saga
these are the core things and these
marvel filmmakers and kevin feige did so
they worked so hard to make them so
specific like the entire movie of
avengers end game is built around this
logic of when stones could be brought
back and how they have to be destroyed
how they have to be returned to maintain
the sacred timeline loki was even very
specific about you know them not
mattering for this show at least in the
boundaries of the tva but then to go
back in different realities and say like
no none of those rules apply it's like
you don't have to bring up the infinity
stones at all and what if you know
there's plenty of stories you can tell
that don't at all bring in the infinity
stones absolutely absolutely like you
don't bring them on screen
it is very interesting that they decided
to make the infinity stones the focus of
this season when marvel studios is very
much moving past the infinity saga right
but you know but then again this is what
if and it does go throughout the
timeline of our it very much relies on
the past 10 11 years of the mcu clearly
the producers of what have said that the
only way to make ultra and a nexus being
is by giving them all six infinity
stones but there's plenty of other ways
he could so many different ways
than just giving him the six infinity
stones if anything that's like a new
rule you're establishing that infinity
stones make you a nexus b and if you
have all six of them i buy it i bought
it in past episodes i just get a little
confused when gamora just says oh the
infinity stone crusher doesn't work now
like
[Laughter]
oh me now
now you decide this logic matters it
just feels a little cheap and uh i uh
like but overall i still really love
this series i just wish they didn't hold
themselves down with these little
moments you know
like just go crazy with it the way in
episode four like with dr strange like
yeah the time stone was being used for
all kinds of crazy stuff but they didn't
like ever i mean they had absolute
points right i guess that was their one
restriction but it had narrative weight
to it like we saw the heartbreak of what
an absolute point did and we saw the
consequences of breaking an absolute
point here it was just kind of brought
up as like
we're in the middle of inception and
inventing new rules just to create
obstacles for ourselves no i definitely
agree with you there and like hopefully
in season two like the logic will be a
little bit more ironed out i think they
could just decide either the logic does
matter or it doesn't matter right but
you just have to stay true to the logic
within your own series the way loki
seemed to be at odds with the logic of
some of the other mcu titles like
avengers infinity war but it stayed true
mostly to its own logic throughout those
six
that's all we really need and then
afterwards as we go on to a new title we
can figure out what pieces of that logic
matter to this world uh but when the
logic changes mid play like that it can
feel a little like whiplashy but overall
i'm super appreciative of this series i
think it was really fun i thought it
created megaphone pristine character
combinations the mul the guardians of
the multiverse i think is one of the
more exciting teams to watch like it i
agree with you it did feel like uh the
avengers versus thanos on titan but just
even more of that and we got to see more
moves i thought it was super fun to
watch especially that mjolnir
multiplying move i love that so much i
have to replay it i was like oh my god
this is so cool i love it uh it will
give us endless stuff to talk about as
we look ahead to future marvel titles
multiverse of madness dr uh doctor
strange's next battle and then uh of
course spiderman no way home and hawkeye
and all these great things we're excited
for and we will be here for all of it
inside marvel isn't going anywhere we
will still be here every single week
talking about the biggest marvel news uh
unwinding and unpacking stuff that we're
still confused about from what if but
that's it for this episode so we want to
thank all of you for watching and empty
thank you to you another great series
that was just made even better another
one in the books bro it's i love
watching marvel series with you bro i
would not want it any other way me too
uh don't forget to check out our merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me at uavos follow mastertainment uh at
uh mastertainment follow new rockstars
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast thank you for watching
and we will close with our favorite
moment of the episode
i can't say i've heard that battle cry
before
[Music]
you